you mentioned your brother and uh it
seems like in the book that you really
had to
uh work hard when you study to to sort
of
um given that you weren't good at
memorization you really truly deeply
wanted to understand the stuff and you
put in the hard work and that seems to
persist throughout your career so
um you know hard work is often
associated with um
sort of has negative association so
maybe with burnout with dissatisfaction
is there some aspect of hard work at the
core of who you are that led to
happiness for you
did you enjoy it I enjoyed it so I will
be the first and I'm I'm really careful
to say that to people because I don't
think everyone should associate G to do
what you did you have to there's only
one route there right and that's just
not true and I I do it because I like it
in fact I'm careful and as time goes on
you have to be careful as more and more
people watch you whether you like it
you're a role model or not you are a
role model for people whether you know
it like it want it does not matter I
learned that the hard way and I would
have to say people hey just because I do
this does not mean I do it for these
reasons right this would be really
explicit and I'd come to believe usually
when people say the word power I don't
know do you have a positive or negative
notion when I say the word power which
is incredibly negative one yeah for some
stereotype or some view that that it
somebody's abused it in some way you can
read the newspaper somebody's doing
something
um personal people like I'll ask people
do you want power and they're like oh no
I'd rather do good yeah and I think the
irony is you need power to do good and
so that sort of led me down to in
it was I thought about my own life right
because it's it starts in a
like many of us you know you don't have
a lot but you don't know that because
you're like everybody else around you at
that time and I want to end tragedy
right my father leaves my mother uh
homeless no money no food nothing four
kids she's never worked a day in her
life outside of a home
and I the irony that I hear I would end
up is the ninth CEO of one of America's
iconic companies and now I co-chair this
group 110 and that journey I said the
biggest thing I learned was you could do
really hard meaningful things in a
positive way so now you ask me about why
do I work so hard
I ended up writing the book in three
pieces
for this reason when you really think of
your life in power
I thought it kind of felt like a pebble
in water like there's a ring about
you really care about yourself and like
the power of yourself power of me
there's a time it transcends to that you
are working with and for others and
another moment when it becomes like
about Society so my hard work
I'd ask you one day sit really hard and
think about when you close your eyes who
do you see from your early life right
and what did you learn and maybe it's
not that hard for you I mean it was
it's funny the things then
if I really looked at it it's no
surprise what I do today and that hard
work part my great grandma as uh you and
I were comparing notes on on Russia
right and never spoke English spoke
Russian came here to this country was a
cleaning person at the Wrigley building
in Chicago
yet if she hadn't saved every dime she
made
my mother wouldn't have a home and
wouldn't have had car right what did I
learn from that hard work in fact
actually she when I went to college
she's like you know you really should be
on a farm you're so big and strong you
know that was her view and then my
grandmother
another tragic life what did she do
though and think how long that's in the
40s the 50s she made lampshades and she
taught me how to sew right so I could
sew clothes when we couldn't afford them
but my my memory of my grandma is
working seven days a week sewing
lampshades and then here comes my mom in
her situation who who climbs her way out
of it so I associate that with well
strong women by the way all strong women
and I associate hard work with
how you are sure you can always take
care of yourself and so I think that the
roots go way back there and they were
always teaching something right my great
grandma was teaching me how to cook how
to work a farm even though I didn't need
to be on a farm my grandma taught me you
know here's how to sew here's how to run
a business and then my mother would
teach us that look but just a little bit
of Education look at the difference it
could make right so anyways that's a
long answer too I think that hard work
thing is really deeply rooted from that
background it gives you a way out from
Hard Times yeah you know I think I've
seen you on other podcasts say
I thought I did do you want to plan B
didn't you say no you would not like a
plan B yeah I don't know because you're
like I would prefer my back up against
am I remembering story like that
you seem to like at least certain
moments in your life seem to uh do well
in Desperate Times true enough I true
enough that's true I I learned that very
well but I also think
um that maybe this is the same kind of
plan B I think of it as like I was
taught like always be able to take care
of yourself
don't have to rely on someone else sure
and and I think that to me so so that's
my plan B I can take care of myself and
it's it's even after what I lived
through with my father I thought well
this set of bar for bad after this
nothing's bad and and that does it's a
very freeing thought the being able to
take care of yourself is that you mean
practically or do you mean just the
self-belief that I'll figure it out I'll
figure it out and practically both right
so you wrote quote I vividly remember
the last two weeks of my freshman year
when I only had 25 cents left I put the
quarter in a clear plastic box on my
desk and just stared at it this is it I
thought no more money
so do you think there's some aspect of
that Financial stress even desperation
just being hungry did that play a role
in that drive that led to your success
to be the the CEO you know one of the
great companies ever it's a really
interesting question because I was just
talking to another colleague who's CEO
of another great American company this
weekend and
he mentioned to me about all this
adversity and he said I said to him I
said
do you think
part of your success is because you had
bad stuff happen yeah
and he said yes you know and so I I
guess I'd be
lying if I didn't say I don't think you
have to have tragedy but it does teach
you like one really important thing is
that there is always a way forward
always and it's in your control I think
there's probably wisdom for mentorship
there or whether you're a parent or a
mentor
that uh easy times don't result in
growth yeah I've heard a lot of my
friends and they they worry they said
geez my kids have never had bad times
yeah and so what you know what happens
here so I don't know is it is it
required
um and why you end up not required but
it sure doesn't hurt you had this good
line about an advice you were given that
growth and comfort never coexist growth
and comfort never coexist and you have
to get used to that thought if someone
said that they think of me like one of
the more profound sort of lessons I had
um in the eyes it's from my husband and
uh which is even more you know funny
actually you could just steal it I mean
you know yeah shamelessly as he'll tell
you
um okay so the story behind growth and
comfort never coexist but honestly
I think it's been a really freeing
thought for me and it's helped me
immensely since
mid-career
and um as I write about it in the book
I'm mid-career and I've been running a
pretty big business actually and the
fella I work for is going to get a new
job it's going to get promoted he calls
me he says hey you're gonna get my job I
really want you to have it and I said to
him no way I I said I'm not ready for
that job I got a lot more things I got
to learn that is like a huge job around
the world every product line development
you name it every function I can't do it
it looked at me
he says well I think you should go to
the interview
I went to interview the next day blah
blah blah guy says to me looks at me and
he says I want to offer you that job
and I said
I would like to think about it I said I
want to go home and talk to my husband
about it
kind of looked at me okay
I went home my husband is sitting there
and he says to me I went on and on about
the story Etc and he says
do you think a man would have answered
it that way and I said
he says I know you he's like six months
you're going to be bored and you all you
can think of is what you don't know and
he said I know these other people you
have way more skill than them and they
think they could do it and he's like why
why and and for me it internalized this
feeling that
and it it I'm gonna I am gonna say
something it's a bit stereotype that it
resonates with many many women and I'll
ask you if it does after is that either
the most harsh critic of themselves and
so this idea that I Won't Grow unless I
can feel uncomfortable doesn't mean I
always have to show it by the way so
that's why I meant growth and comfort
can never coexist so I got I was like
he's exactly right now the end of that
story is I went in I took the job when I
went back to the man who was really my
mentor looking out for me and he he
looked at me and he said don't ever do
that again and I said I understand
because it was okay to be uncomfortable
I didn't have to use I mean
now I would take stack of the things I
can do right and really think or I look
for times to be uncomfortable because I
know if I am nervous
like I don't know if you're nervous to
meet me we never met in real percent I'm
still terrified no you're not but then
it means you're learning something right
holding it together so well that to me
matters I think it's interesting the
maybe you could speak to the the sort of
the self-critical thing inside your
inside your brain because I think
sometimes
um it's talked about that women have
that
um but I have that definitely and I
think that's not just solely property in
the workplace but I also want to sort of
push back on the idea that that's a bad
thing that you should silence because I
think that anxiety that leads to growth
also that's like this discomfort so
there's this weird balance you have to
have between that self-critical engine
and confidence yeah I think that's a
good point you have to kind of dance
because if you're super confident people
will value you higher that's important
but if you're way too confident maybe in
the short term you'll gain but in the
long term you won't grow very good point
so I can't really disagree with that and
and to me even when I took on jobs
I always felt people say well is it you
know what point are you confident enough
and I came to sort of believe again a
theme of my beliefs that
if I was willing to ask lots of
questions and understood enough that's
all I needed to know